so today we're going to talk about zinc
okay in the seven weird signs of a zinc
deficiency zinc is a trace mineral which
is different than a mineral and all that
means is you need trace amounts very
small amounts something usually below a
hundred milligrams but you still need it
it's very very essential most people
when they think of a zinc deficiency
they may think of acne because of all
the acne creams have zinc in it or maybe
for sunburn to protect you against the
UV light but it's also involved with the
loss of taste and smell slow wound
healing hypogonadism which means that
your testicles are smaller and you're
not producing testosterone it can come
from a zinc deficiency arthritis any
inflammatory condition could be a zinc
deficiency but I want to talk about the
seven kind of strange symptoms that
maybe you've never heard about stretch
marks could be a zinc deficiency poor
hair and nail growth the white spots on
your nails that could be a zinc
deficiency which is interesting because
if you see it right in the center and
your nail it's a grows every six months
and it's right in the center we pretty
much know about three months ago
you consumed a lot of carbohydrates you
may have had a birthday party and you
ate the whole cake because that sugar
will pull zinc out and it leaves the
little white spots number for high blood
pressure could be related to a zinc
deficiency cold extremities dwarfism
hearing loss as you're getting older
could be a zinc deficiency so you could
be zinc deficient not necessarily from
not eating a certain amount of food left
by eating the wrong foods processed
foods refined foods especially we're
fine grains deplete your zinc whole
grains will deplete your zinc because
they have something called phytate in
the fiber which actually binds with the
zinc and you can't absorb it cooking
will dissolve the zinc and it goes out
through the water refined sugar will
actually block the absorption zinc
stress will deplete your zinc liver
damage like in fatty liver liver that's
has cirrhosis will block the absorption
of zinc colon damage diverticulitis
irritable
syndrome things like that can block your
absorption of zinc so the core essence
of what zinc does
it's a coenzyme for many many things in
the body okay many chemical reactions
what does that mean coenzyme it means
that it's an essential element that
makes the enzyme work and without it
it's not gonna work
the enzymes do the work of the body so
you can look at zinc as an essential
thing that allows something to happen
either approaching to be made or DNA to
be synthesized or created it helps make
DNA as you can see there's so many
different bad effects that can occur if
you don't have enough zinc the three
primary areas that it'll effect would be
skin a lot of different skin issues
immune system think about when you start
getting run down or cold usually the
cold remedies out there have zinc in
them especially as a preventive action
also the lining of your intestines
alright how do you get zinc well seafood
especially oysters okay high in zinc
seaweed a very good source of zinc plant
basic fish in general liver like
grass-fed liver meats animal products
veggies have some and nuts have some as
well but you also want to avoid the
things that deplete the zinc now lastly
there's a really cool test that you can
get it's called a zinc test and what you
do is you put a little bit of zinc on
your tongue and if you taste nothing
that means you're deficient in zinc okay
but if you can taste a very strong
metallic taste that means you have
enough zinc so it's a very simple test
I'll put a couple links down below of
different brands that you might want to
check out but it's a very simple way to
do a quick test to see if your zinc
deficient alright I'll see in the next
video I just wanted to say thank you so
much for watching my videos I really
appreciate it and if you wouldn't mind
giving me a review I put a link down
below